[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAY SMITH: Welcome to
CE TV on Cloud OnAir.
Live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Jay Smith.
And today I'll be talking to
Gwen Shapira from Confluent.
How are you doing today?
GWEN SHAPIRA: Fantastic
being with you.
JAY SMITH: I want to make
sure you all know that you can
ask questions on our platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
And we might answer
some of them later on.
Let's get started.
Actually I had the pleasure
of meeting Gwen a few times.
And she was at
Strata New York City,
and got to see some
interesting stuff.
She's kind of the
guru here about Kafka.
GWEN SHAPIRA: That
was a fun event.
I hope you also enjoyed it.
JAY SMITH: I did.
So let's get a little
bit of your background.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yes.
So I work for Confluent.
It's a company that was
started by the people who
first created Apache Kafka.
And do we do
all-Kafka-all-the-time from
support to building a lot
of tools that make it easier
to run, to running it ourself
on Confluent Cloud among others
on Google Cloud.
So basically, I want to be here
today to kind of talk to you
about Kafka and
how people use it.
And what's going on there.
JAY SMITH: Awesome.
Let's get right to it then.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah
so I was thinking
of starting with just a simple
stream processing example
to explain what we're
talking about when
we say that Apache Kafka is
really a streaming platform.
And then do a quick intro to
just the concepts of Kafka
and the components around it.
Show two, maybe even
three, cool use cases.
And then jump into
a demo and show you
how we implement
those use cases.
I got really cool demo for you.
JAY SMITH: Excellent.
I like cool demos.
So do our viewers.
GWEN SHAPIRA: So basically we
say that Kafka is a streaming
platform.
What does it actually mean?
It means that you
can produce events.
Kafka will store them as an
ordered stream of events.
It will maintain this order.
And then you can
consume those events.
And you can even consume
them, do stuff to them,
and write them back
to Kafka, which is
what we call stream processing.
Just to show you what stream
processing could look like--
imagine someone trying to
bring a credit card processor.
So you get a lot of
authorization attempts
from credit cards every day--
like thousands and thousands
every second.
A tiny percentage of them
could be incredibly suspicious.
So we need to detect
the suspicious events
and separate them
from the good events.
And basically have
someone investigate
them a bit more, right?
And it sounds like it
could be very complicated.
To be honest, doing it in real
life is pretty complicated.
But it can start with
something incredibly simple.
If someone is trying
to repeatedly authorize
the same card over
and over again,
it's probably very suspicious.
So we want to basically
filter the stream
of authorization attempts
for this kind of behavior.
And create a new
stream of things
that may possibly be wrong.
And we want to do it every
time an event happens.
We want to do it continuously.
That's the core of
stream processing.
Not just once a day because
then the bad guys may be already
all the way back to somewhere.
And who knows.
We may never catch them again.
So we want to
continuously process it.
And as you can see, using
KSQL is the simplest way
to do stream processing
even if you know almost
nothing about streams or Java.
JAY SMITH: Right.
This looks very similar
to your standard SQL.
Maybe a few little differences.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Exactly.
So just to show you how it
works, we basically say OK,
we're creating a new
stream of possible frauds
based on an existing stream
of authorization attempts.
And the way we
select possible fraud
is that we look at
five-minute windows.
So we cut down the stream
into five minutes windows.
Pick the card number and count
the authorization attempts
of this card in this window.
And then say everything
with more than three
in a five-minute window
looks like a suspicious card.
And we're writing it
as possible fraud.
And then we have
an ongoing stream
of things that look suspicious.
Now we want to basically
send it somewhere else
for deeper analysis, where
maybe a qualified human can
do extra investigation.
So really, the core
idea of streaming
is that you don't process
events once in a while,
you process them as they're
going on in real time.
If you learn nothing
else about processing,
that is the concept
you have to remember.
So how do we do it?
So let's look at the components
that make up this platform.
And the core component
is the Kafka brokers
or what we also call a
log or a distributed log.
There is a famous book
by my CEO, Jay Kreps,
called "I Love Logs"
where he basically
explains that log is the
fundamental data structure
of all modern computing.
And it turns out that logs
are incredibly simple.
It is a data structure where
you write things at the end
and you store the
structure in order
for a set amount of time,
which could be forever.
Some people do hundreds
of years amount of time.
And you can see that this
could be your application log,
this can be a click stream,
this can be a credit card
authorization attempt.
The message is so generic.
Like an event is-- anything
that has happened could be it.
And you keep writing
events at the end
and then different
applications want to read it.
And the idea is that every
application is independent.
And they start at some
point, usually the beginning.
And they continue
in one direction,
hopefully to the end.
And there is one
direction of movement,
which makes it just efficient
on disks and this kind of stuff.
And also each one of
those consumers only
needs to know OK, the last
message I got is message five.
The next one is going
to be message six.
Let me ping the broker and
say, can I get message six?
Can I get message seven?
You get a bit more than
just the next message.
But that's the idea.
Which means that the
clients and a broker
don't need to keep track
of every single event.
And did everyone consume it?
And who is supposed
to consume it?
This is one of the
things that we are always
a bit more
computationally-intensive and
memory-intensive in
all the message bases
and really set Kafka apart.
JAY SMITH: So since
its all in order,
its easier to keep track of.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yes.
Exactly.
You just have to remember
one number per consumer.
So sometimes people ask
me how many consumers can
I have with Kafka?
And I know 2,000.
50,000.
It's just one number.
How much does it long take?
Right?
And then I just showed you
one log, which in Kafka terms
is one partition.
A Kafka topic is made up
of a lot of partitions.
I think the topic is kind
of this logical entity--
maybe like that base table--
then Kafka is made up of
a lot of those topics.
I'm going to show you a lot
of topics when we do the demo.
But that the idea is
that the topic will
have many partitions.
You can spread them
across many machines.
You can have many
producers writing to them.
Many consumers reading.
So it's really a
scalable system.
The other thing is that each
partition is also replicated,
usually on streamed machines.
So you have a leader.
All reads and writes
go to the leader.
And then their
followers basically
keep replicating syncs.
You have one job.
Keep replicating it.
And if something
happens to the leader,
basically, one of the
replicas take over.
The idea is that because
all reads and writes
have been leader, we always
have full consistency
on that partition.
Which is really a core
guarantee that Kafka has.
JAY SMITH: That's good.
I mean, if you have all of those
events and one of the machines
goes down, heaven forbid--
you want to make sure you
can maintain those events.
So having this replica
technology built in to Kafka--
GWEN SHAPIRA: Exactly.
And usually when
things go wrong,
it's because people
misconfigure replication.
And think that they have
guarantees that they actually
don't.
So you can see
here's that it's kind
of really scalable
end-to-end-- from producers
through partitions to consumers.
And consumers really have
the idea of consumer group.
So if one consumer instance
cannot handle all the data from
all the partitions because
thousands of credit cards per
second is a lot of work, you
can actually start multiple
instances and belong to
the same consumer group.
And they will basically
negotiate with each other
and say, OK, this one is
reading this partition,
the other one is reading
the other partition.
And you get scalability on
the consumer applications.
And also high-availability
if one of those crashes,
basically the partitions will
get reassigned to someone else.
So it's really scalable
and resilient end-to-end.
And then if you go to the
Apache-Kafka projects,
you'll only really get
clients in two languages--
the Java and Scala.
But Kafka has a binary protocol
that is only slightly complex.
So let's look inside
of the implementing
this binary protocol
in different languages.
So you have a
pretty big ecosystem
in all those
different languages.
And then if your language
is not supported,
you have arrest proxies
that will give you support.
Pretty much everyone
does REST, right?
JAY SMITH: Exactly.
And that's great
because a lot of times
when you want to
learn a new tool,
there's a limitation
based on whatever software
or whatever language
it supports.
But being able to support
a wide array of languages,
I can just take whatever
knowledge I have today
and take advantage
of the REST proxy.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Do you
notice that we're
expected to learn new languages
faster than we did in the past?
JAY SMITH: Oh, yeah.
There's like three new ones
every month or something.
GWEN SHAPIRA: I know.
I spent most of my
career with Java.
And then suddenly it's like,
oh, I have to learn GO.
And now I was told that
Trust is the really big deal.
And [INAUDIBLE]
is a really big--
Everything keeps happening.
And it's funny, I have a friend
who is now learning REST.
And he is like, do you think
I can just write a Kafka
producer as my first project?
And I'm like, go for it, man.
JAY SMITH: Maybe he'll
write one in Julia too now.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Ooh, maybe
if you have spare time.
I don't know, do
you do hack projects
and that kind of thing?
JAY SMITH: Sure, why not?
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah,
20% time, right?
That's the--
So until now, I
kind of explained
how you produce and consume
events from your applications
that you coded yourself.
But there is a lot of cases
where the data you want
is not something that you
actually create yourself.
It actually already
exists in some database.
And you can't really
ask the person
writing to do their
best to please
also write to Kafka because
they have their own priorities.
Well, you can really
connect to the database
and get events to Kafka
with the Connect framework.
I mean, you could write it
yourself in your own app.
But there is so much
in common between all
those different
pull-and-produce loops
that we figured that we may
as well give you the framework
and let you focus on how to
query the Azure database.
So it's a very basic idea.
Did you get that from a database
into Kafka, or from Kafka
into a database?
You don't have to
do the entire flow.
Just half of it is fine.
But you know, then we'll
show you the entire flow.
And obviously once
you write a good API,
communities are kind of amazing.
So hundreds of
Connect-ers showed up
from all those different
teams and companies
like the connector from
Kafka to Google BigQuery
was written by a
company called WePay.
And they just the
open-sourced it.
And now 10 other
companies also use it,
because apparently getting
data from Kafka to BigQuery
is a very big thing.
JAY SMITH: Right.
Apache Kafka, we must
emphasize the fact
that it is open source.
It is very community-driven.
Confluent is very active
in that community.
So you do get a lot of
these third-party connectors
and tools built for it due
to its open-source nature.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Exactly.
And for me, it's just always
amazing the creativity
of the community.
Did you ever want to get events
from a Bloomberg terminal
into an IRC channel,
for example?
And then the last
component is really
doing with the
stream processing.
And I kind of already showed you
how it works in the beginning.
So I don't have to
go over that again.
But I wanted to mention that
this is kind of friendly SQL,
but its a layer on top of
a Java API and a Scala API
is that you can really
use more directly if you
prefer using Java and Scala--
which a lot of us really do.
And it does give you a bit
more power and flexibility
at the expense of
slightly more complexity.
Which seems like
the usual tradeoff
in pretty much everything.
JAY SMITH: Right.
Now being able to
essentially query the stream.
So as its writing
to the logs, you're
able to get information
not actually just waiting
until it actually is written.
GWEN SHAPIRA: And I'll show you
that on screen in real time.
Just type a query and
see the events come in.
It's pretty awesome.
And this is like six
lines of code, or so.
And it's six lines
because we broke it up.
I wrote the same thing in Java.
And it wasn't huge
amounts of code.
But it was definitely three
screenfuls of lines written.
So having the ability
to really do it quickly
is pretty big for
busy developers.
So what can we do with this?
Our listeners at home
may want to go and write
their own stream
processing framework.
What could they do?
So one thing that we see very
often is how companies have
those clicks of events that are
actually meaningful information
that they want to analyze--
sometimes from web applications
or mobile apps--
and then they may want to
enrich the event with things
that they know about the users.
So some profit that comes
from a database query.
Maybe even log files
to see if there
was correlation with different
errors that happened.
And you can really
bring all of those
into Kafka, probably
into different topics.
Use KSQL to join,
window, aggregate,
do whatever you want.
And then you can really
stream the events
into external systems
like Google BigQuery.
So you can do more
analytical work.
And that's one
thing to emphasize.
KSQL is fantastic for
kind of data-managing,
joining, grouping.
And it works real
nicely in real time.
But it's not like please
query the last five
years of data kind of thing.
And there is a lot of
stuff that really you
want to write the data
to an external system
so you can do a lot more
involved analytical work.
JAY SMITH: Right.
So you wouldn't necessarily
try to train a model with KSQL.
Just more like getting
the information that you
need to train the model.
GWEN SHAPIRA: And you know
before you find a model,
you really need clean,
high-quality data.
This is where we see the
connectors and the KSQL
really come in.
But the big question is,
how do we actually do it?
How do we get data
from Kafka to BigQuery?
And it's one of the things
that I had my own opinion.
And I said it's obvious.
And then I asked other people.
And they had their opinion
and they said it's obvious.
So I want to go
through some options.
So the old school way is
through something called Secor,
which is basically a batch job.
Highly parallelized back job.
So think of it as a
big mass-produced job.
And it basically goes,
connects to Kafka,
starts consuming events,
and writes them to BigQuery.
But this is a batch-up.
So it's run once an hour or so.
And while it's pretty cool,
and it's flexible, and does
all kind of cool things--
We did a lot of
work to make sure we
get the data in real time.
We don't want to lose
the real-time aspect just
before we land in BigQuery.
So we also picked up a
bunch of streaming options.
And you can use stream
processing frameworks.
And they give us examples--
Kafka Streams, and Apache Beam,
and obviously Google Dataflow.
And being full-fledged
programming languages,
it gives you a lot of
control over what your data
is going to look like.
So if you need to do a
lot of standardization,
a lot of clean-up, get
some data over here,
some data over there,
a bunch of filtering--
You can really write those
jobs and basically get events,
clean them up, write
them to BigQuery.
Of course, it's programming.
So you have to
actually write all
of it yourself-- all
the error-handling, all
the scheme-handling.
All those is your own code.
And Kafka Connect is pretty
much the polar opposite.
It's still streaming.
But it's basically
a no-code option.
I'll show you.
Basically, write a big
configuration file.
And you say, OK,
I'm getting data
from this topic to this BigQuery
data set into that table.
And you expect Kafka Connect
to handle everything for you,
more or less.
It's kind of like,
if this does the job,
you're done in five
minutes, while writing code
can take a big testing cycle.
And if you actually
need the controls, and--
I mean, it would be nice if I
could do it in five minutes.
But I can't.
JAY SMITH: So it's great
for getting started.
GWEN SHAPIRA: It's amazing
I'll show you how quickly
you can get it done.
I'm thinking that
these days engineering
is under a lot of
stress to deliver things
in very short time cycle.
And a lot of times, you
have to show results
before you get allocated the
time to do anything smarter.
So, like, look at I'm getting
events from Kafka to BigQuery.
Fantastic.
Oh I really need the events in
a slightly different format.
So let's bring it to
the next two weeks.
I'm going to really try to do
something a bit more involved.
And then, once we know how
to collect a lot of events
into Kafka and writes them into
BigQuery, why stop with clicks?
I mean, there is a lot of
useful data in those legacy data
systems and in
their applications.
And you can use it for
example, maybe running a bank
and you have your
credit card processing.
You have transactions, and
you have loan requests.
And you have a lot
of old information
about the customer's
legacy systems.
Bringing them all together and
processing them, getting them
to Google BigQuery with
things like Connect or Google
Dataflow, depending
on the use case.
And then you really have a
lot of data here to process.
Imagine trying to get access
to the data on the legacy
mainframe.
And the tools you would
have to use to do it.
And then just how
long the processes
take versus doing the
experimentation in data
as it shows up in real time.
It's a very big difference
in quality of life.
And then if you got the
simple use cases working,
you can do things that are more
advanced and obviously more
exciting.
I think it's more exciting.
A lot of the data business
comes from devices.
JAY SMITH: Yes it does.
The IoT has made my life
easier, maybe a tad lazier.
All of my outlets are wired.
And I just speak into my Google
Home and turn on everything,
turn off everything.
GWEN SHAPIRA: You
actually do that?
JAY SMITH: Yeah.
GWEN SHAPIRA:
That's pretty cool.
I'm not that advanced.
But I do have things like Nest
and those programmable light
bulbs.
If you want to set up
a modem in my house.
And it's a lot of fun.
So basically all
of those devices
speak a very small
number of protocols.
A common one is MQTT.
And part of that the Confluent
platform is an MQTT proxy.
So you can really collect
information from those devices,
stream it into the cloud.
The nice thing about
clouds is, there's probably
a cloud center near
a region nearby
from where the device is.
And then you can really
start doing advanced things.
Like, you can train a model.
And using the same
data, you can also
serve the model in real time.
Something like Google
Function serving up the model
on every event as it happens.
So you can really start with
something fairly pedestrian
like clickstream
processing and end up
with a real time
machine learning
IoT system that is
probably something that you
can raise some money with.
So obviously with all that,
you want to actually use
all those cool tools.
You don't necessarily
want to install them,
configures them, figure out
why they are losing data.
Or maybe they're not
losing data and why
they are not losing data.
Why they are not losing
data, but doing it
too slow, or too fast.
Managing it, upgrading
it, troubleshooting it,
getting the pager at 3 AM.
Have you ever had a pager job?
JAY SMITH: Not for a while.
But I do remember
getting those alerts
in the middle of the night.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah,
I'm just thinking,
my last pager job
was maybe in 2009.
I do not miss that at all.
So basically introducing the--
or not introducing, it's
been around for a while.
But the idea is that if
you could write yourself,
Kafka is open source.
You're can install and run it.
Or you can let us run it for
you on the Google platform.
And I'll show you.
It's kind of integrated
with the rest of the Google
platform with those connectors.
JAY SMITH: Yeah, one thing I
always tell users, developers.
You know, when you're
building your application,
if it's not something that
is core to your project--
If it's something that
you need but managing it
doesn't really add value--
it's always best to have
somebody else manage it.
That way you can focus all
your time, resources, energies,
onto the things that actually
matter for your application.
And for your business.
GWEN SHAPIRA: And the
really funny thing
is that I've been working
with the same companies
for a bunch of years now.
And it's funny
how companies that
three years ago were like, we
are never going to use cloud.
Clouds will not work
for our banking system.
And then three years
later, are like,
oh you know we are actually
starting to move to the cloud.
We could use some help.
What's a good architecture
for migrating to the cloud?
What's a good use case?
How do you do cloud security?
And I think it's in
just the economics of it
are kind of individual.
Why would you want to run
your own data center it's not
your competency?
JAY SMITH: Absolutely.
It just doesn't
make sense to do it
if it doesn't benefit
your application
at the end of the day.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Exactly.
Focus on things you
are actually good at.
In banking case,
taking our money.
JAY SMITH: Let's look at
Confluent Cloud, then.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yes.
Let me try to switch to my demo.
So I'm already logged
into the Confluent Cloud.
And you can see that I basically
have a bunch of clusters
already here.
If I want to add a new one,
it's really not a big deal.
So let's say I want
to test something new.
And you can see I can play
around with how much data
I am time consuming
and producing.
Important bit is to select the
right provider, right region,
how many availability zones.
And then we click continue.
And look, this is
going to cost us,
say, half a dollar per hour.
And we're here for an hour.
So I think you better pay up.
JAY SMITH: All right.
I'll send it to you
over Google Pay.
GWEN SHAPIRA: OK.
So after I launch the
cluster, I basically
see a bunch of instructions on
how to install a C Cloud, which
is inspired by G Cloud--
which we all know and love.
And this allows me to
basically use the cloud
from the command line.
Basically I can do something
like C Cloud topics list.
And because I'm
already connected
to one of my
clusters, you can see
I have a pretty big list
of topics going on here.
I wish I sorted them.
It's kind of not really sorted.
I can create a new topic.
That's going to be
kind of a new topic.
And I can produce events
into a topic if I want to.
So you want me to show
you how to produce events
in to a topic?
JAY SMITH: Sure, let's do that.
GWEN SHAPIRA: So this was
the new topic I created.
OK, so I produced an
event, super-simple.
And now I want to
obviously consume it.
And I'm doing [INAUDIBLE]
to start consuming
from the beginning.
Otherwise, you only
get new events.
And you'll see that they are
starting for a long time.
Why is nothing showing up?
So this does take a
bit of time because we
need to negotiate
the consumer group.
And see if someone
else's connects.
But soon enough, here is a load.
So hey, if you're
following at home,
this may be the first
event you and consume.
I know for me, when
I teach classes,
it's always exciting to see
people produce and consume
their first event.
But what I really
wanted to show you
is how you build a pipeline.
So how I get events
from Wikipedia.
And maybe run a KSQL query.
And then write them to BigQuery.
You can show me how to
do a query on BigQuery.
So I'm switching to
Confluent control center.
And basically, I can
see all the topics here.
But I really wanted to
show you the connectors.
So you can see that they
have a Wikipedia connector.
And the only expense--
as connectors, they
don't require to write code.
You basically configure them.
So over here.
I basically configured
the Wikipedia server.
It's an RC server.
Wikipedia publishes
everything that
happens to a bunch of channels.
And you can see all the
channels that I'm reading from.
It's basically a channel
for every language.
And I'm writing all of them
to the same Wikipedia topic.
So let me start that.
And then let's go
and look at the data.
So I'm looking for
the Wikipedia topic.
When I click here, you can see
that I have a bunch of screen
so I can see the
schema in the topic.
And I can take a look.
You can see this is
real-time events.
You can see more
events are coming in.
And I can see the new events.
And so you can
actually see the data.
So we're combing Wikipedia.
And this user edited this page.
He put in this message.
I find it pretty cool.
Now if you want to actually
run a query, I can go--
Oh, it's unable to connect.
I cannot run queries for you.
I'm sorry.
JAY SMITH: It's all right.
Let's see what else
we can do here.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah.
That's what happens
on the things
that you didn't test
the night before.
Pretty much, that's
how demos work.
But I can go to the
sync and basically
say, so Wikipedia
edits will not exist,
because that's the
one with the things
that we were supposed
to get processed.
But we can still get Wikipedia
events into BigQuery.
So we edit here.
And here, you can see
that I'm getting events
from those two topics.
And I'm basically mapping them.
Go to Wikipedia edits.
Wikipedia goes to Wikipedia.
So that's basically a topic
to table mapping for BigQuery.
And you can say, this
is my BigQuery project.
And the name of the
data set is Wikipedia.
It took me a long
time to figure out
how all this terminology works.
But it's the same terminology
if you know BigQuery.
It will probably be a lot easier
for you than it was for me.
I figured out how to use the
JSON key file to actually
authorize my BigQuery user.
And so now after I
figure this all out,
I can start my connector.
I don't know how to switch tabs.
So it's going to
be that hard way.
So this is my Google Dashboard.
And here I have BigQuery.
This is the data set.
And I have to create a data set.
But before I start
the connector,
I had to create a
Wikipedia data set.
But the tables will basically
be automatically created
based on the mapping.
And their schema will
be automatically created
based on the schema
of the events in Kafka
that I showed you.
And if I make a change
to the event in Kafka--
if I could use KSQL to
actually edit the events--
the change will automatically
reflect in BigQuery.
So that's pretty cool.
And it actually shows
me all my query history.
I didn't know it does that.
That's neat.
So it can actually,
as well, do something
like, you can see all of
those were Wikipedia edits.
But I want to do
something from--
does it do auto-complete?
Had the source.
Can I talk to a product manager?
I want auto-complete.
JAY SMITH: We'll
put it on the list.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Then let's get
just like a few of those.
OK, let me see.
If I click here, it will
just run the query for me?
Query table, yeah.
Oh I needed to have the
fully-qualified table now.
Hopefully, we don't have
results from today yet.
JAY SMITH: No, it's still new.
That's all right, though.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah that's
a risk of live demos.
JAY SMITH: Looks
like all of them.
We've all been there.
GWEN SHAPIRA: You can see here
basically the Wikipedia pages.
You can see the channels.
I can also show you
since I think I still
have all data from
the Wikipedia edits,
I can probably show you how
I enriched it with KSQL.
But when KSQL still
worked for me.
JAY SMITH: You might want
to get rid of the partition.
Give an asterisk too.
GWEN SHAPIRA: I really like
how it shows the arrows
that they have.
That's super-helpful.
And now it's going to work.
See, it parses
everything in real time.
Real time just adds
a lot more usability
to pretty much everything.
So you can see here is that
I added a readable date.
So now you know that I did
all my practice five days ago.
And if you go to the end, you
can see that I edited language.
The way I edited
the language, is
that it's based on channel
line was like fr dot Wikipedia.
I basically joined
it with a table
that I created that has mapping
of the channel to the language.
And then I could
do a join and get--
Yeah.
That is pretty awesome.
So basically, this allows us
to get events from Wikipedia
to Kafka.
If we are lucky it will do
some extreme processing.
And then use Connect to
write the events to BigQuery.
And all that in real time.
JAY SMITH: And this is just
one of the many ways we can
use Kafka and Confluent Cloud.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Exactly.
Yes.
And the next time, we'll
try to demo TensorFlow.
With a small IoT device that
kind of drives around here.
Just in case people
want to try it.
Here we are.
And basically, we have a
Confluent Cloud professional,
which is exactly the
OIs that I showed you.
So you can just, you write
Confluent.cloud or you
go to that URL.
And you basically
sign up and you say,
it's like half a
dollar per hour.
And building this pipeline takes
just I don't know, an hour.
And it's basically
something that you can
get started with fairly easily.
JAY SMITH: All right.
Well that was great.
Stay tuned for a live
Q&A. We will come back
in about a minute.
And we will answer your
questions about Confluent Cloud
and Kafka.
Welcome back.
Looks like we've got some
really good questions.
So why don't we jump
right into them?
How secure is data
in Confluent Cloud?
What measures do you have
in place to protect data?
GWEN SHAPIRA: Isn't it the
first thing that everyone always
asks about the cloud?
How do you keep our data safe?
So Kafka itself has
basically the authorization,
authentication, encryption-- the
things you need to keep safe.
In Confluent Cloud by
default, all the communication
is SSL encrypted.
So you have encryption
in the wire.
We use encrypted storage
to store the data.
So you have encryption on disk.
And you authorize
which is basically,
you get an API key and a secret.
As long as you keep them safe.
we don't even know them.
And basically, that's the
authentication method.
If you are even more
paranoid than that.
I mean in this case, I
exposed my Kafka to the world.
Like I could just
use it from my laptop
from the Google
Wi-Fi with no issues.
But if you want to
limit the access
to just who's in
your own data center,
and just within
your company VPN,
then we also
support VPC peering.
So you can use this to have an
even more secure experience.
To be honest, I'm exposing my
toy clusters to the internet.
But I wouldn't probably
do it if it was actually
running my bank.
JAY SMITH: And then being
hosted on Google Cloud,
you guys get to have the
added benefit of the security
that Google Cloud offers.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yes.
For example, your load
balancer is probably
what keeps us safe
from DDoS attacks.
JAY SMITH: We currently
have some applications
running in our data center.
But we would also like to
use BigQuery in real-time
with data generated by our
on-premises applications.
Is this possible with Kafka?
GWEN SHAPIRA: I think I just
showed that it is, right?
I mean, you don't have to
get data from Wikipedia.
It was a cute demo,
but then you can really
get the data from
anything that you produce
to Kafka on Google Cloud.
You can use Connect and
the BigQuery connector
to get the data to
Google BigQuery.
If you don't want to use
the BigQuery connector,
you can also use Data Flow,
or Kafka Streams, or something
[? better, ?] or code that you
wrote yourself, because you
are not a invented here person.
The sky's the limit.
JAY SMITH: All right.
With that REST API, you
were able to write a lot.
We have implemented
Kafka ourselves
and have been running
it for three years now.
As Kafka adoption increased, we
are experiencing some issues.
It is lagging quite a bit.
And this is impacting
our business.
Do you have any recommendations
on what we should look into?
GWEN SHAPIRA: Oh,
tuning is a big topic.
So I'm going to
assume that you're
running on Confluent Cloud.
And obviously, the [INAUDIBLE]
are running perfectly well.
So it's really more about
looking into your consumers--
like your application,
why is it lagging?
So first of all, kudos for
noticing that your application
is lagging.
We've seen people who do
not monitor consumer lag,
and therefore don't even know
that their application is
lagging.
So if you are monitoring it
and you know it's lagging,
you're already a step
ahead of everyone else.
And then, most
lag-monitoring tools--
definitely in Control Center,
but I think also the rest
of them--
is they will basically show
you what the lag looks like.
Is it increasing or decreasing?
You fell behind and
you cannot catch up?
It will also show you how
many partitions you have,
how many consumers you have,
and the lag on each partition.
So you can say, oh,
actually this consumer
is reading from five
partitions, while the other two
consumers are barely
reading from two partitions.
And we need to somehow reassign
partitions and rebalance,
because it's clear why
this one is falling behind.
You can say, oh, it's one
consumer, 100 partitions,
loss of data gets returned.
It may have been OK 10
years ago, maybe not OK now.
And then sometimes you also have
a problem where one partition
just gets more data.
And you need to consider the
keys that you're writing.
How do you really distribute
the events to partitions
to avoid this kind of
skew, because it can also
cause you to lag.
If you're running
Kafka yourself,
obviously there is a lot
of issues that can happen.
It can be that a
broker is handling
a lot more logs than the rest.
And you need to rebalance.
It can be that you have a
bad disk for that matter.
It can be a lot of
different things.
JAY SMITH: That helps narrow
it down a little bit though.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Just a tiny bit.
That's the nice thing about not
running the broker yourself.
At least you know
that this part--
you figure it out who
has a call to support.
And then you only have
to worry about the rest.
JAY SMITH: We are
cloud-native company
and are looking for
Kafka as a service.
What are some things
we should consider when
selecting a particular service?
Good question.
We have a lot of people nowadays
that are born in the cloud.
Their applications never saw
an on-premise data center.
GWEN SHAPIRA: For me, I'm
very much open-source person.
I think you should
try to avoid look-in.
And try to make sure
you're using open source
software, open standards.
And just look at the
community and make sure
that you're working
with the communities
that you enjoy working with.
You obviously want to make
sure that the people who
are running the
software are actually
capable of supporting it.
I guess it is, but this
is just due diligence.
I'm trying to see.
Do you have suggestions?
JAY SMITH: Testimonials
is always a good thing.
Whenever I am
looking for somebody,
I try to find somebody
who else has used it.
What did they use?
How they felt about it.
It's important to
emphasize though,
that Confluent has a lot of the
original designers, creators
of Kafka.
So that's one way.
That's a little bit of
a selling point there.
GWEN SHAPIRA: And as I said,
is that just as a developer,
you want to work
with nice tools.
I think the reasons that
I enjoy Google Cloud
and really was something we
tried to emulate in Confluent
Cloud is really have
a nice command line,
APIs that are usable.
Just make sure that
it's a good-- you're
going to spend a lot of
time in that environment
if you're a developer.
So it has to be a
nice environment.
JAY SMITH: Final question, we
are heavily invested in GCP
and are adopting Kafka.
Is Confluent Kafka
the same as GCP Kafka?
Is it a native GCP service?
Well, I can answer the GCP part.
Today we do not have
a managed Kafka.
But we have a partnership
with Confluent
to provide you
managed Kafka on GCP.
GWEN SHAPIRA: So the
big difference I guess,
is that if it's not
an active GCP service,
you don't get to see it on
the big Google Dashboard where
a so BigQuery, for example.
But other than
that, we are running
on the GCP infrastructure.
I think specifically, on GKE.
We're using all the
available Google tooling.
It is not a GCP Kafka.
But hopefully you kind
of get a GCP experience
that you know and love.
JAY SMITH: Right.
And running Confluent
Cloud on GCP,
you can integrate with
every other GCP tool
like we saw BigQuery earlier.
Maybe a cloud machine learning
engine, Cloud Functions,
App Engine--
pretty much anything
you see on GCP.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Yeah.
I haven't shown that,
but I'm actually
running a Kafka Streams
job running on Google GKE.
So the Google Kubernetes Engine.
And that connects to
my Confluent Cloud.
And as a way to integrate you
apps with the whole Google
ecosystem.
JAY SMITH: I think
that's all the questions
we have for today.
I'd like to thank you,
Gwen for coming out.
GWEN SHAPIRA: Thank you
so much for inviting me.
JAY SMITH: Sharing with the
world everything about Kafka
and Confluent Cloud and
how it can take your events
to the next level in the
events that your apps generate.
And your devices,
those smart switches,
and cameras and everything.
GWEN SHAPIRA: And keep
everything real time.
JAY SMITH: So stay tuned
for the next session.
"Add a Rich Geospatial
Analysis to your Toolbox
with BigQuery GIS."
Thank you very much.
GWEN SHAPIRA: It's
all about BigQuery.
You could get the GIS
to BigQuery with Kafka.
And then do the
special analysis.
JAY SMITH: There you go.